After repeated head impacts, experienced in
sports like American Football, the brain can
begin to shrink and deform, causing dementia-like
symptoms.
Why is this happening and can we stop it?
Howdy gang, I'm Trace, thanks for watching
DNews today.
Chronic traumatic encephalopathy or CTE is
a serious condition first discovered in the
1920s with boxers, because boxers get hit
in the head, a lot… both during practice
and during a match.
According to one medical examiner in a 1928
issue of the Journal of the American Medical
Association, "nearly one half of the fighters
who have stayed in the game long enough" will
experience something they called being, "punch
drunk," "slug nutty," or, peculiarly, "cutting
paper dolls."
In the 20s they termed this dementia pugilistica
-- word of the day: pugilist, which means
boxer, but today, we call this derangement
CTE.
Even nearly 100 years ago, these specialists
were recognizing repeated cranial impact has
huge implications.
The brain is bound by the same laws of physics
as everything else and thus will move until
something stops it, namely, the skull, this
is called a concussion.
And even a minor one, has a serious affect
on your brainbox.
If the smack is hard enough, the brain tissues
can become deformed or permanently damaged,
even lesser sub-concussions, when taken together,
can affect the brain long-term.
Basically, any activity where the head comes
to a sudden stop, repeatedly, has the potential
to trigger concussions, and additively will
cause this degenerative brain disease.
CTE has been found in people who play American
football, ice hockey, soccer, rugby, boxing,
and wrestling, plus members of the military!
Even people who only played in high school
can develop CTE.
This is shocking stuff!
And I just want to stop and say, more pads
can not stop the brain from moving INSIDE
the skull, any more than a larger bumpers
stop a person moving in a car crash.
In another study from the 1920s, boxers’
brains were looked at after death, in an autopsy,
which is when they realized something was
wrong… their brains had atrophied, or shrunk.
CTE is
difficult to diagnose, because it manifests
as behavioral changes that mimic other brain
disorders like Alzheimer's or Parkinson's.
Once the neurons and axons in the brain are
permanently altered from the repeated impacts
so to is behavior, emotional control, memory,
reasoning skills, physical and mental controls…
CTE affects everything.
The brain reacts to these impacts by literally
shrinking -- called cerebral atrophy.
In modern studies, doctors found as much as
a 30 percent loss of the frontal, parietal,
and temporal lobes!
The damage centers on collections of neurons,
infused with a protein called tau.
Tau normally helps stabilize neurons in the
brain, but in CTE it manifests as neurofibrillary
tangles, turning the brain a yellow color.
Neurofibrillary tangles are literally that,
they look like the tau protein threads have
become bundled up and though how this happens
isn't entirely understood by science, all
the patients have these tau tangles.
In the end, as the brain shrinks and the amount
of tangles grows, the person gets more aggressive
and less emotionally and physically stable,
and, frighteningly, more suicidal.
Obviously, this is all bad.
CTE, Alzheimer's and Parkinson's are all tauopathic
diseases, and unfortunately, research on living
people with these disorders is still ongoing,
and as of now there's no cure.
Which means, once CTE sets in, usually in
middle age, decades after the repeated impacts
occurred, nothing can be done.
Chronic traumatic encephalopathy is manifesting
in athlete after athlete, because they've
spent their whole careers smashing into one
another, either on purpose or on accident;
and even this week, there was another death
attributed to the mental anguish that comes
along with this brain disorder.
In the end, our brains are the source of everything
we are.
Sometimes, concussions can knock a person
unconscious, or worse, they can slip into
a coma, but what exactly IS a coma?
I've looked into that too, right here.
Does the discovery of CTE and it's mental
and behavioral consequences make you think
twice about joining sports?
Or for encouraging athletes to hit each other
for our entertainment?